avant de développer ses titres les
questions autour des antennes relais en
ville comme à la campagne ces
équipements sont de plus en plus
nombreux par endroit leur installation
provoque des réactions hostiles
certains estiment que ces antennes sont
dangereuses pour la santé
même si les premières études françaises
n'ont pas établi de risque
nathalie perez vous aviez roman
catherine vivent est ici en plein centre
de bordeaux
mais depuis deux mois elle est partie
s'installer chez sa soeur elle ne
revient que pour entretenir son jardin
et écouter ses messages
c'est cette antenne qui selon elle est à
l'origine de ces troubles de santé
apparu il ya deux ans et qui l'ont
obligé à quitter son domicile à j'ai des
maux de tête une crainte complètement
enflammé des palpitations des nausées
bon ce sont des symptômes qui se sont
installés au fil et à mesure du temps en
fait et qui essaie ça devenait de plus
en plus insupportable donc j'ai été
obligé carrément de fuir en france il
n'existe pas d'étude qui établissent
formellement la nocivité des antennes
mais ce scientifique a recensé toutes
celles faites chez nos voisins européens
on peut avoir éventuellement
la naissance de pathologies lourdes
suite à quelques quelques années par
exemple d'exposition à ces émissions
mais ceci pour l'instant n'est pas
parfaitement établie disons qu'on a
quand même des craintes notamment en
raison du fait que ces antennes ont été
installées partout qu'elles ont été
installés près des écoles près des lieux
de vie ici à quelques kilomètres de
bordeaux en pleine zone rurale et au
milieu des habitations
l'opérateur sfr s'apprête à installer
une antenne de 45 mètres de haut à la
place de ce relais radio qui lui mesure
dit m tout le village est mobilisée
contre le projet là aussi faute de
données françaises on s'est appuyé sur
les études sanitaires fait à l'étranger
la suède l'allemagne ou même aux états
unis en fait certains états ont pris des
mesures genre pas de pylônes à 600
mètres des habitations
ensuite on a vu les risques sur le plan
sanitaire
là quand on a vu la liste des risques va
commencer un peu à être à la fois énervé
et paniqués par ce qu'il a c'est
vraiment pas possible
des propos qui dérange d'ailleurs
l'opérateur sfr 1 refusé de répondre à
nos questions cependant l'agencé
française de sécurité sanitaire dans son
dernier rapport ne parle toujours pas de
risque pour la santé
elle déconseille seulement l'usagé du
téléphone portable aux enfants de moins
de 10 ans